Kevin Buck and we have the directors of the box trolls.
[inaudible]
so Tony stocky and Graham a animal.
So I,
let's take a look at the trailer for boxtrolls.
Oh,
oh,
they've got the flowers and the trees
and then,
yeah.
First
of all,
thank you for inviting us.
Um,
and then,
uh,
you know,
when we first saw that trailer that they were going to release,
we objected immediately.
We said,
there's no way that you can show how we build the characters before the movie
even comes out.
Don't you all them at their faces off.
But in fact,
we were totally wrong because what people have found the most interesting about
that,
and especially in the more and more we travel on Showpad,
is the fact that these are handmade objects.
That these are tangible things that really exist in the real world.
Um,
and you know,
every animator and every filmmaker's quest is to put together something that
nobody's ever seen before.
Something that,
that,
you know,
it used to be like when we were young,
when you saw your first CG animated dinosaur running across a field or the water
tentacle in the abyss,
it seemed every few years and there was something else amazing that you've seen.
But nowadays we have so many amazing visual images that we see that it's become
sort of passe.
So our quest on this movie,
you know,
the fact that Alan's knows book here be monsters,
had this great Victorian setting and like a had been a studio,
they'd been together for three films at this point that we could put together
something that would be a visual sort of feast,
something that nobody had ever seen before.
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
stop motion has a tendency to feel like it's shot on a tabletop set and that's
because it's shot on a tabletop set.
Um,
and so we knew with a lot of lessons learned on Coraline and paranormal and we
were going to find ways to try to bring a bigger sense of scope scale to the
film.
We wanted this big comedic adventure,
the boxtrolls to,
to feel different.
And yet preserve what was special about stop motion.
So it really approached this film is as a hybrid.
Uh,
you know,
at its core it is stop motion,
it's still puppets and it still sets.
But we found all kinds of new ways in different ways to integrate our VFX
department to bring that world to a larger scale than I think audiences are had
ever seen before in a stop motion movie.
And it all started about 10 years ago when like I bought the rights to Alan's
knows book here,
be monsters,
which is a fantastic Dickensian steampunk tail sort of smashed together with a
Monty python tone,
which we loved right away.
Well Robin was love was the fact that it truly is a cast of thousands in a,
in the book.
And part of Alan's knows appeal in his writing is that he is every page creating
new characters to get the old characters that are the situations.
And we knew very early on we weren't going to be able to maintain that kind of
pace with building puppets.
So we eventually gravitated to the most compelling and mentioned that Alan had
in the Bush book,
which was the boxtrolls.
Um,
and it was the emotional story of these little boxes,
all characters raising,
uh,
this character Arthur in the book that became the heart of the story and was
what we rallied around and it sort of became a rule.
Uh,
Travis describes it as ruthless economy.
Once we knew that that emotional story was the boxtrolls and eggs,
the everything else had to get thrown out and it can only creep back into the
movie,
fight its way back into the story.
Yeah.
If it's supported that emotional core,
but it's a long journey.
Figuring out stories.
I mean here be monsters was
bought at like at the same time as core line.
So it's been pretty much 10 years to get to this point.
I'm actually making the film
and you know,
every animated film is storyboarded first.
That's the way we get to make the film.
Before we make the film,
we storyboard the whole thing out.
We record 10 voices to figure out our performances before we actually go to the
final actors.
And get there,
you know,
go to Sir Ben Kingsley or Nick Frost or Simon Pegg and then get the final voices
which we need before we commence animation,
so we spend a long time,
each story real is like a rewrite is like rewriting the script and you've see if
the story works and then you present it to everybody at the studio.
So in this process,
what you're always looking forward for that one sequence where you feel this is
the movie,
this has the emotional tone,
the action tone has that you want the final movie to have because once you have
that one sequence that really works,
we call it the tent pole sequence.
Then you throw everything else out and you start over building out from that one
sequence and early on in the process.
This sequence here was the one that was that tentpole sequence
roles.
Where'd it go?
Turn around.
Moving.
Okay.
Yeah.
There was a lot of things that we loved about the sequence,
the relationship between the boxtrolls and the baby and stuff that just gave us
this little bread crumbs.
We needed to find the core of the story.
But the funny thing was story of course is that yeah,
we basically threw everything out that came before the sequence.
Everything that came after the sequence and built the whole movie from this
sequence because this was working and within about three months we cut this
sequence.
It's just kind of the way it goes,
but it allows you that step.
It pointed us in the direction down the road.
We knew we needed to go with the movie and so yeah,
there's a great,
there's a famous guy,
Joe ramped who's ahead of story at Pixar for years and a lot of other places and
he always used to teach that you have to trust the process even though it feels
like you're not making any progress and that you've gone down another dead end
or something like that than if you just trust in the process that you are making
progress and you will find the story.
So we felt on track with the story at this point and we moved on for what we
call the look of picture and when we immediately on reading the book we'd
thought of a few artists we wanted to work with.
We started to work with a French artist named Nicola de Cressey use,
a French graphic novelist who has an amazing ability to draw images of these
great European cities.
He hasn't really great shape language that he draws in and there's this
beautiful line quality and the ways he draws.
So we worked with him for a few weeks to get some inspirational sketches.
He's definitely the best person in the world that drunk piles of junk,
which was a real boon for us.
He also did this image of a,
of a chandelier made by the boxtrolls underground and it's a,
you know,
it's from light bulbs that they've collected in the garbage and wires that
they've found and stuff.
And there was something about this image that really struck home with us and
Travis Knight,
I'm the CEO of like a where we loved the idea of this thing.
We loved getting to know the characters who would build something like this.
And we all looked forward to the people that like are actually building
something like this with their amazing abilities.
Um,
so we moved forward from there and we had a guy,
a guy named Michelle Burton who had worked on Coraline previously at the studio
and he began to hone all of these ideas into what we call the look of picture
book.
And it's a book that we hand out to all 400 people who work on the job
eventually in the fabrication department,
in the puppet department and,
and all the rigging department.
So they know the set of rules that everything in the movie has to go by,
whether it's a,
a torque shape that's twisting,
a little has thick and thin lines on it has color and stuff.
Yeah.
And it was a real challenge for the art department to figure out ways that Wa,
you know,
a huge part of what Michelle does so well is his line work as you can see in
this image.
And they had to find all kinds of ways to represent that wonky realism that
Michelle brought to everything through his line work.
And the scale of,
of this film was going to be a huge challenge,
but a Kurd annually,
our art director was able to find ways using shadows and shapes and color,
um,
buildings beyond just twisted light poles and chandelier is to find ways to
bring that shape language that Michelle had created into the film.
Okay.
This is a love that,
this is the Portland Ryan's for ea of the building and it's another chandelier.
I clearly love chandelier.
This chandelier was built by Kurt in the art department on a twisted wire and
stuff.
So that became the first object that we really loved.
The thought captured Michelle's drawing style in the world of the film because
you don't get anything free and animation,
and particularly in stop motion,
anything that appears in front of the camera has to be built.
It has to be made.
We don't inherit any of the prompts from paranorman or Coraline because they're
done in a different style.
Yeah.
So once the image is started to land in black and white,
um,
we move forward with policy and great matte painter and production designer in
La.
And we definitely wanted to make a stop motion movie that wasn't too dark beyond
just making a stop motion movie that felt bigger in terms of scale.
We also wanted to see what we can do to bring brightness color to a stop motion
feature.
Cause that's another aspect of it that they tend to have saturated pallets and a
lot of stop motion movies and it's great.
It's wonderful.
It's an effective thing.
But we really wanted to see and push the studio to try to do something a little
more colorful.
And Paula saying was the perfect guy to bring that to the film he had,
he'd worked on Dick Tracy.
He really knew how to bring color into things.
He also did a great job of,
um,
color styling the Boxville cabin because the bookstore cavern itself as a
location is almost a character in the film because at the beginning of the film,
it's supposed to be a warm,
inviting place where the,
the hero eggs is raised.
But it's little by little,
it becomes a depressing,
drab place as more and more Brock strolls are kidnapped by the men and red hats.
So he did a great job.
We did that predominantly through light and color.
Yeah.
Now it's found yourselves in a weird spot because usually when you develop a
feature,
you kind of start with your characters and your character design first.
And then the world kind of begins around that.
But Michelle,
Paul and Tom [inaudible] had done such a tremendous job and quickly figuring out
the shape,
language and realizing the world we had the world before.
We really had the characters nailed.
And that put Mike Smith and amazing two d animator in the interesting position
of utilizing what he saw in Michele's world to bring characters that would fit
within it.
Um,
and he worked much like Michelle had done where he worked in silhouette first
and began to then put in the details and get that again,
that shape language to show up in the actual characters as well as the buildings
and the,
and the world around them.
And we were still going through a lot of story changes at one point.
Um,
rather than having an allergy to cheese,
um,
snapchat had a really bad case of x,
y a phobia.
He was afraid of horses,
but he dreamed of being the man on a horse who rides into town and is creating,
you know,
and it's met as a hero and stuff.
So that was another sort of dead end we went through in story when we kind of
struck upon this idea of him having this cheese allergy,
which isn't in the book,
but it's similar to something in the book.
Um,
we knew it would be a huge test of the department that makes the faces for our
movie.
Um,
also in the storyboarding process,
we fell in love with all these ideas of what the box stores could do with their
boxes.
Yeah.
Initially the puppet department was really excited when this project got green
lit because they were like,
wow,
finally a movie where we've gotten a lot of the main characters wearing a
massive boxes,
we can just hide all the mechanics in there.
This is going to be a breeze.
Uh,
I quickly turned into a nightmare for them because as the board's evolved and as
the story evolved,
we just kept putting the boxtrolls into situations where we had more and more
special case things that they needed to do.
And they very soon realized there was no way they were going to be able to fit
into it and had to come up with a lot of innovative methods to,
uh,
to get the boxtrolls to feel and look and work for the story.
You know,
the boxtrolls hide in their boxes.
So the way that's done,
because there was so much rigging inside the boxtrolls boxes,
their arms can actually retract into the boxes.
There's enough movement in the shoulders or the arms,
so they can begin the motion in,
but then there's shorter and shorter arms are made to click on.
So it looks like they retract into the box the same as the head.
The head can begin its motion down and then there's smaller and smaller heads
that you click on.
So they appear to disappear into their boxes,
which is one reason why an animation you do things fast because then you use
fewer and fewer in between frames to get where you want to go.
Quick is good.
Yeah.
But even before then we wanted to,
we wanted to,
there's an old,
there's an old test that you do in animation was you animate a flour sack,
just a flour sack to see if you can give it personality and you can give it
expression and emotion.
You can make the flour sacks of sag or be excited and stuff.
So we wanted that kind of bend to bill in the,
in our hard boxes too.
So then it became a long run of testing boxes.
So this is what we did for months.
We played with cardboard boxes
and then were also trying to find a material that would look like cardboard.
Okay.
And not be too rigid.
Yeah.
Originally they didn't try using cardboard,
but it just,
there was no way it was going to hold up to the rigorous shooting schedule.
So this is an early task where we're getting the amount of movement that we
wanted out of them.
We'd also done tests where they moved like chimpanzees or move like different
animals,
but more and more we found that their character came through
much better if you kept it simple.
Okay.
This was the first test that made us all think,
oh,
we made it not be idiot.
This might actually work because he was such a lovable little guy.
We also combined a few other extinct forms of animation at Laika.
Um,
we do a lot of two d animation,
traditional hand drawn animation in our process.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
I mean it's all tied into our RP process.
The face replacement animation that we do and it utilizes
right from the beginning of the model sheets of the expressions that are drawn
in two d are then handed to uh,
an excellent two d animator,
David Vandervort in the studio who,
uh,
fully animates and pencil tests,
the complete range of each character's emotion.
Like try to figure out exactly how extreme all the face masses are going to move
for each character,
happiest,
angriest,
all the expressions they could possibly do using,
usually hopefully finished dialogue if we have it available.
And that then that two d animation then becomes the guide that is handed over to
the CGI Three d animators and Maya,
who then begin to build the faces in the computer digitally and get all the face
expressions working.
And then that once that gets approved by the directors becomes the faces that
get printed physically out of the three d printer and then get put onto the
puppet.
And this is an example of the faces that are printed from the gun and we print
these by thousands.
Yeah.
For eggs.
Real nuance of change of x had about 15,000 pieces created for his face,
for the film,
which in different combinations,
because they're usually actually typically split between the brow and the mouth.
And so all those different combinations with the 15,000 pieces allowed for about
1.4 million possible expressions,
which I think I've got about six.
So exit is a little ahead of me and there's a whole like Dewey decimal system of
how we track these things of what the expression is doing.
Usually the faces are split along here,
so you have different eyebrows that can go along with different miles.
And there's a whole room that we call the face library where there was boxes of
these that are basically like a pizza box and they're full of phase after phase
after phase,
we have a little clip that shows you the process.
If I get this back on,
mate,
cue you mate.
Yeah.
We knew from from paranorman that you know,
we had this color printing process that worked really well,
but it worked well to produce some naturalistic skin tones and now looking at
these really vibrant sort of theatrical paint jobs that the directors wanted on
box trolls.
We were sort of scratching your head saying,
well in theory the machines can do it,
but we don't really know if they can do it and maybe they can do at once,
but are they going to be repeatable?
If you get a beautiful paint job,
how has that paint job going to animate?
And we came up with a way to do it and it worked really well.
Looking at how we were able to improve the process on Paranorman and then
looking at this script to boxtrolls and he's really specialty story moments.
We needed to have something unique.
Then allergies.
Snatcher is a perfect example of that.
Their scores.
His face has so much swollen weirdness to it that having him say a line of
dialogue,
you get so much follow through with his cheeks and his lips shopping on the
torsion that it really,
we learned very early on that there was way that we can try to recycle these
poses.
You don't Tuck Joel,
hey,
so what we decided to do was tackle every single one of allergy snatcher shots
as its own unique animation and then we would have to print out those faces,
faces.
They were so big,
we were only able to print 12 faces and 12 hours and how many can you usually do
in 12 hours?
Probably 150 of like eggs as an example,
not like them.
You have no idea that this thing that you're watching,
this creature is not real because of the amount of nuance and subtlety and
naturalism that we were able to put into these faces.
They feel like they're really little creatures.
Would skin and movable muscles and volume change and will you pick them up and
you tap on their faces?
They're just a hard plaster that isn't movable.
But through replacement animation,
we get some really lovely and smooth animation
so that,
so that's,
that's probably the most high tech element we've added to stop motion stop
motion is,
is a,
is a technique that is old oldest cinema itself.
I mean George Mellie is the French great French signup filmmaker was doing it at
the turn of the century and stuff.
And then there's been a long line of,
of individuals throughout cinema who've continued to move it forward.
George Powell did replacement animation in the 30s and forties and stuff.
And then what Travis has done it like,
or his vision for like it is to try to take this group of people,
which he likes to describe as Luddites and futurists and have them share more
than a parking lot,
having them share a whole studio.
And early on they brought this rapid prototype process to Coraline and at first
the faces were only printed in black and white and they had to be hand painted.
And then on Paranorman they were able to print them with a little bit of color
on them.
Um,
freckles and a little bit of rouge on the cheeks and stuff.
And then for our film it took another great leap forward.
As you can see,
these faces are very elaborately colored.
Yeah.
It creates a kind of bizarre step in our process.
So it definitely has directors is then there's a phase where we approved
storyboards and the story real.
Uh,
and then when the RP folks get involved,
uh,
it's an interesting thing for the animators because it sort of divvies up their
performance,
their overall performance.
They need to basically sit down with their assigned shot in storyboard form and
begin to visualize the entire performance.
But focus just on the face performance up front because productionwise those
faces need to get signed off on and approved and then printed so that they're
ready for the stage.
May Be anywhere from one or two weeks to two months down the line.
And so they need to sort of figure out their entire face performance up front,
get us to sign off on it and then find themselves two months later sitting with
that pizza tray with the faces that they chose.
We all toes a few months ago and make sure that the performance they had in
their head that was going to work with that face all comes together.
And the way they get us to sign off on it is they send us what we call a play
blast,
which is there Maya animation,
three d CG animation of the face shapes.
They send it to editorial and we cut it into the story reels on top of the
storyboard drawings.
Yeah.
So this is the Maya animation of the faces prior to being printed out.
So we look at the performance on here
and we can add in betweens or say this a little bit further and oftentimes later
in the seed production cycle will how already have these printed faces.
So we'll say use those faces that we used in sequence 32,
um,
where,
uh,
you know,
fish's face was much more angry.
Use those mouths.
And it's really a,
it's a,
it's an amazing,
you know,
we say it sometimes it's animation by librarians because it's amazing that
they've made these many faces that can move in and out of so many different
poses without there being a pop.
There was a moment right there where you see face a fish's face kind of stretch
a bit with the nose.
That's because the animator wanted to try to have a little rub with the puppet
hand on the face.
Uh,
when he went was we're going to be out on the stage with the final uh,
puppet.
But that's like,
again,
that's scary sort of commitment upfront because he's got to figure out guests at
the time and he's going to use for how long that hand's going to rub that face.
And we all again have to sort of commit up front to like,
that's the faces we're going to use for this.
And here's the final version of it when the faces are actually all together.
Okay.
Eh,
that's the final shot of that.
Yeah.
One of the things we do in our process as well as we have breakdown meetings,
which is where all the heads,
all the futurists and all the Luddites and the heads of their departments come
together for the meeting where we break down each sequence of the film shot by
shot.
And it's always kind of an incredible process and very energetic meetings.
Everybody comes in there with their homework already done and it shot by shot.
Different departments are vying for why they should or shouldn't be involved in
each piece and who's gonna do what basically.
And again,
because this film right from the get go was going to be a hybrid and a real use
and of the VFX department,
uh,
you know,
the digital guys were involved heavily with the whole process.
But at the end of the day it always came down to what delivered the style of the
film best.
And so we had a lot of surprising inventions always from our rigging and,
and puppet departments where practical effects showed up in places where we
didn't even anticipate.
Yeah.
For me,
I,
I've worked in stock stop motion a little bit in my past,
but prior to that I mostly worked on CG films and usually on a CG film,
you know,
the issues that you're going to confront.
We need for,
we need wet for,
we need a snow storm,
we need to develop all this stuff.
Um,
when I was really surprised at the culture at [inaudible] is a lot of those
decisions are made till the 11th hour.
You have this break meeting and people are still discussing how are we going to
do the water in the sewer?
And I can't,
you know,
I know we're going into production on that shot and I could never get used to
the fact that it weighed into this,
this late hour for this meeting for to happen.
There's a shot in the movie of eggs in the sewer and he's going to go above
ground.
And usually in something like that you would use CG to do water because water's
very difficult to do in any kind of traditional form of animation stuff.
But at this meeting we ended up having a totally different way of it being done.
Yeah,
there's nothing that exists before we start on one of these films.
Every single thing that you see has got to be designed and built by hand.
You don't get anything for free and stop motion.
We've really got to plan out every single element and that goes as far as the
fire and the smoke and water and all the natural elements that you see on
screen.
Tell me an art director.
It's awesome.
I mean how often do you get to create everything?
I mean that's an incredible sense of power.
One of the things is incredibly difficult to do.
Stop motion film is bring the environment to live in a believable way and it's
something that was very important for us in this film to have that level of
atmosphere.
We talk about what's water going to look like,
what's the destruction,
what's dusk going to look like,
what are the materials that we would use to create these images and that's where
we start your calling change night cha.
We created this entire sewer system with flowing water and dripping water out of
just plastic and glass.
What we have behind me is a sheet of glass that has ripples in it and it's made
from shower glass and that's passing from left to right.
And that's given us half the flow.
And then what we've done is we've created a little nest out mirrors and wires
and good sip blue masking tape.
And so what we're seeing is we're seeing the effect of the ripple glass passing
over those wires and mirrors.
And that's given us the illusion of the highlights above ground [inaudible],
the 24 25 different kinds of weeds that we have growing in cheese bridge are all
specific weeds,
but yet they're sort of stylized in a way,
puts them into our world,
which I think is the important thing a new species ever seen before
for the fire.
We did a lot of early tests on uh,
with using cheese cloth.
Our rigging department with did this amazing series of flames and this amazing
fire and I've just using suspended upside down.
She's cloth hit with that kind of have this orange yellowish light.
I looked incredible.
The attraction to making like natural elements is harshly the challenge of
taking on nature.
You just become more appreciative of things you take for granted by delving so
much deeper into the subject.
And when you've got it,
you just feel like you're kind of neck and neck with nature.
There's quiet,
empowering feeling about it,
trying to emulate nature
in the end.
It doesn't matter how you get there,
as long as you can reproduce the style of the film the best way.
So every film is different,
you know,
a lot of special effects houses and their goal is to have everything and look
realistic to look real for RV effects department.
Their problem is that every film is stylistically different.
So they need to make it look like that.
Like we use CG extra characters in the background and they have to be
indistinguishable from these puppets and all of their texture and form and all
the effects has to do that.
Probably not a frame in the film that doesn't have some sort of CG,
um,
assistance to it.
Whether it's compositing or adding atmosphere and stuff.
We've got three
clips here.
They give you a sense of just how much did the effects department helped out in
certain sequences.
Now the core of every sequence is always at the core of it.
It is a stop motion feature because it is always puppets and anything that they
touch and interact with his physical as a set
rig removal.
Then adding the farm background,
far distant atmosphere,
closer atmosphere.
Then we start to drop into CG city because they're not going to interact with
the city.
In this shot.
Then is the atmosphere between the characters and the camera.
There's an all CG city all rendered on style.
Now.
We built a lot of those buildings whenever the characters had to interact with
them,
but in this scene they had to match the look of those built buildings,
adding more atmosphere and chimney smoke.
Here's the red hats,
pursuing eggs,
fish and shoe.
Their animation element is comped in the far background with cheesecloth crowd
clouds that were generated by the art department and then we put in more
atmosphere in the city.
Now this next shot,
everything that the character's touch,
every rooftop and stuff is real,
but everything else is CG set extension
rig removal.
This film too,
we used extensively a previous department to help for a lot of these action
sequences to really figure out the scope of each of the shots and to maximize or
minimize how much overbuilding would happen.
So we knew exactly what the characters are going to interact with before we
went out to the sets and how much coverage we were going to need.
And that's important to bear.
Took,
took a few months,
uh,
the board and figure out and stuff and we thought,
oh yeah,
secret 700.
That's how we know the mother names sequence 700.
That's going to be the hardest to rooftop chase or sequence 2150.
The battle at the end of the movie,
we're snatcher destroys the market square in the giant Mecca drill.
Now that'll be the hardest one.
And we were wrong both times cause we didn't have any idea what we were doing.
Yeah.
The hardest thing to do in the boxtrolls and far and away was ballroom dancing.
Nearly killed the studio.
Yeah.
That really kind of caught us off guard and a,
and it really did Max out every department in the building and as described
earlier,
the breakdown meetings that we have,
this is I was when Tony and I realized we were in a lot of trouble because
again,
those meetings,
just coffee and cookies and everybody's chatting and it's very,
it's got a lot of energy to it.
We walked into the room for the breakdown meeting for the dance sequence.
Dead quiet,
nobody was talking.
No one would even make eye contact with us.
Everyone they knew better than we knew.
Yeah.
They all just were quietly leafing through their packets,
looking at each other like,
we can't,
how do we do this?
Every,
every department?
It was a difficult thing to storyboard is a great store,
burned on a Emmanuella Cozzi who boarded the whole sequence.
Then Darrio Marinelli be a composer,
had to write a brand new waltz and also make it score in different places.
A little bit more romantic,
a little bit more action oriented.
And then we are hired to choreographers from the Portland ballet to come out and
reproduce the entire dance sequence on one of our stages and we shot it there.
Then we did a CG pre-visit of that too,
so we could figure out the speed of the camera rotations and movement as were
swirling amongst the dancers.
Um,
and then the animation people had to come in and figure out a way to make the
skirts on the female characters that they could dance with because underneath
those skirts and there are no legs and stuff,
there's just like a slinky apparatus.
So you make the skirt go up and down and swirl around.
There was even a shot in the middle of the sequence where eggs hides underneath
the skirts,
which we knew would be impossible because the skirts that we had built didn't
seem to lift high enough to do it.
And so you had that nightmare scenario for us,
which is a real character touching a CG element,
touching a CG element and trying to do that is really difficult.
Um,
anyways,
we continue forward and this is Yon Mohs,
the animator
and time lapse animating eggs in Winnie's entry into the dance.
So it's pretty rare that he was able to animate even with stairs and walls in
the background.
Usually those had to be composited in because animator access to something,
you have to worry about.
The enemies have to be able to comfortably reach the puppets at all time.
So most of the time for the sequence,
he was just born in characters on the parquet floor and we would add everything
else in compositing and the VFX department after that,
um,
it,
it was incredibly difficult for [inaudible] to do.
Um,
that was tricky.
All of us too because out of all the sequences in the film,
this one was the most sort of pieced apart for the longest time in the
production scheduling.
So we never knew how all these pieces were treating.
Unfortunately for us gets done in the summer.
Yeah,
it gets,
uh,
it gets awful hot in the summer.
So we had to visit yon with the shirt off,
which more terrifying than snatcher.
So this is the exciting life of a stop motion animator.
And then when you see the sequence in the film,
you'll realize that the camera is doing a lot.
But if that's the camera in the upper right is doing elaborate camera,
move up into the air.
And then the whole room was full of CG,
extra dancing around these characters.
And again,
it took,
it took all 18 months of our shooting schedule to produce
a little less than two minutes to finish the footage in the film.
And here's who can show you that sequence.
Now
they'd have to be real,
but the Muslim,
the rest of the characters,
we have to get to your folder.
You can't just cut through
this lunch.
This is that shot the yon was working on.
Just make a box.
You might be get out of a box.
It
snatches him
book
a
going on.
Yeah.
So usually when we do this,
we do this talk and say dreamworks or Pixar or Disney,
you can see all the CG animators going,
why would you even do a movie?
Like what is the point?
You know?
And,
and,
and for us it is because there we think there is a special quality,
you know,
and I think,
I think Travis is idea of,
of of updating the company as much as possible.
Sort of dragging this technique in this art style into the future,
um,
is predicated on that idea that there's something unique looking.
And for me the idea is just it's deep down in the DNA and in your subconscious.
Everybody remembers playing with dolls or playing with a model train set of
moving something around and giving something a little bit of life.
And these objects,
the fact that when you look at them on the screen,
they don't look like CG generated characters.
They don't look like real people.
They look like tangible objects that you can grab.
And we've seen it over and over again in every place we go to is that people
just can't keep their hands off our puppets.
As soon as they see them they want to grab him.
And there was was just a New York and there was about 30 young girls who came
screaming down after the Q.
And.
A.
We just have a lot of steroid up.
So,
and that's something among even stop motion animators is,
is it when they bill look at your designs and they'll look at your mcats and
stuff and they'll say,
yeah,
I like it.
I like the idea of and stuff.
But when they look at it puppet that they can't keep their hands off of that.
They really want to start animating.
That's when you know,
you really have something.
So that's why we,
we think we have this big quest for this technique and for this look.
Yeah.
I think for a lot of folks,
even if they're not aware of the process,
when they watch,
I like a film,
they feel that indifference.
It is something unique and find a kind of funny in this day and age where so
many animated features are CG generated that in a weird way,
we like her giving audiences something new by doing something so incredibly old.
Um,
so it's Kinda,
it's a very unique place to work.
And we show the was,
she shows up.
Yup.
Boxes on the hillside boxes,
all the same.
And there's a pain.
Agree
DNA or look,
just the same
are
saying.
Yeah.
Uh,
Tony again.
Thank you.
That's awesome.
That's a really,
really good insight to everything.
And so I kind of wanna talk about you guys kind of interest kind of how you got
brought into this project.
So Tony,
you have been around for while in the industry,
I mean you work all the way back in special effects with as an effects animator
on back to the future and hook and in racketeer and goes to James and the giant
peach was,
can I have your first experience in stop motion?
Is that Kinda what drew you in animation?
I,
no,
I actually,
prior to that,
um,
I worked at,
I went to school at Calarts,
California Institute of the arts from above,
you know,
in the mid eighties and after that I worked in the salt mines of animation in
Saturday morning cartoons and Korea and Japan and Taiwan.
So I did my time and the,
and the spice minds of castle and then animation,
working on [inaudible] adventures and Papaya in the stone age.
And stuff.
So I was used to working on crap.
So I got really lucky.
Later I moved to San Francisco and I worked at a place called colossal pictures,
which was a fantastic advertising studio that did a lot of mixed media and stop
motion.
So you've got a chance to try a lot of different styles.
Then I started working at Ilm and then working in story at PDI dreamworks and
stuff.
So the bay area had quite a few studios at that time and it was a great area to
work in.
You could jump around and do a lot of different stuff.
So I kept getting a taste of stop motion with Henry Selick on James and the
giant peach and a colossal.
And even at that point it Ilm,
they still did some stuff practically rocketeer was done with,
with stop motion.
So I kept getting in good taste of it,
but I'd never got to work on a whole feature.
So when the opportunity came up to visit friends at Leica about seven years ago,
uh,
who were working on Coraline,
I jumped at it and that's when I met Travis Knight.
And he gave me ounce knows book to read
and Grammar.
Yeah.
Uh,
well I,
I tend to chair it in college in Canada and spent a bit of time in Toronto and I
got an opportunity at one point too.
I was animating at that point,
I got an opportunity to storyboard for Chuck Jones.
They were making theater shorts back in the early nineties.
And I got this amazing opportunities,
spend a week in La and sit with Chuck Jones and another group of other story
artists and workout all these theaters shorts.
And I came away from that experience going,
wow,
I want to be a storyboard artist.
That's,
that's my thing.
And then I spent 15 years living in the bay area working as an animator and
video games.
But during that time,
uh,
I continued to do,
I've been doing a lot of comic book stuff and I'd done my own series of comic
stories under the name Brickell.
And that was the thing that I guess Henry Selick saw,
uh,
up in Portland when he was beginning to assemble a team for Coraline.
And he offered this opportunity for me to come up and be a story artist on his
team.
So I showed up there and have never looked back since I've been at like a
storyboard and on Coraline paranorman and during a low on Paranorman I got an
opportunity to do some storyboarding for Tony while he was developing here be
monsters.
And that sort of morphed into me sitting in a chair beside him.
Co-Directing it.
So not,
so what was the big difference for you because you've worked on
obviously Coraline then paranorman of seeing kind of the progression of stop
motion that you guys have obviously pioneered here.
I'm the kind of the blend between CGI and stuff,
but being a story ours,
where have you kind of seeing the being a story artist?
For me personally,
uh,
you know,
I felt like on my resume it says I've worked on to stop motion features and Cole
Haan Paradigm.
And I figured I knew what was involved with the process.
I didn't,
uh,
there was so much more going on past the point when it leaves the story
department that I'd only presume to know.
I always describe it as feeling like a guy who got really good at making paper
airplanes and then suddenly finding himself at the controls of a seven 47 there
was just so many more decisions to make a,
and it's just,
it's been an incredible,
it was,
it's been an incredible ride the last three years making this film and I was
very thankful to have this guy with me because the experience that you had in
directing features before was was huge.
Cause
you,
you mentioned something to me earlier,
which was about kind of your eye.
What stop motion is,
it kind of brings the worst aspects of live action and give it a stop motion.
100 Years of stop motion has figured out a way to combine all the worst
attributes of animation and live action production and combining them all
together in one cocktail of fear and alienation because it,
it has none of the benefits.
If you work in traditional animation,
even in CG animation,
it's a very iterative,
iterative process.
You do a rough version,
you show it to the director of your ad frames,
you pull frames out,
you push the poses a little bit more,
you work on your faces and a little by little you build the performance you
want.
In live action,
you do as many takes as you want with the actors until you get the shot that you
want stuff and stop motion.
It's very different because in stop motion,
once you've got your faces prepared in the storyboards and ready,
you bring the animator in and you've may have been working on this moment for
two or three years,
but it all comes down to that animator launch.
The moment you sit down and he explained to the animator what you want and at
that point he gets what we call a block,
which is essentially just posing the puppet mon six frames or eight frames.
Now usually you animate on twos or ones we animate on ones,
which means we move the puppet every single frame.
And so you get a block to start off with,
which may just be figuring out it's going to take fish four steps to make it
across the room that he's in the shot and there may be a camera move.
So the block is very rough and it doesn't have anything to do with performance.
And then the animator gets one rehearsal where he does the shot on twos to
figure it out and that becomes his breadcrumbs.
And after that he does it for the final version and there's no going back.
Once he begins to animate the puppet from position a to position B two position.
See he's committed to all of that movement.
You can't go back and tweak any of those poses earlier and that is just,
it's nerve wracking era.
No one,
nobody gets into animation to perform in front of a crew of live action.
Guys standing over your shoulder while you spend two weeks moving a puppet
across the screen and stuff.
Cause it,
we described it as it's opening night yet every day for 18 months with no
rehearsals,
theater to the,
I think it's that same sort of stress of like you give them as much information
as he can possibly do and then they get pushed out on stage and that's the
performance you'll get forevermore.
And the film.
Yeah,
it's cool.
It's like nothing else.
And you know,
in tech maybe even though this is an American film,
has a lot of British influences,
you know,
and just some of them,
I mean,
you know,
everyone obviously speaks with a British accent and then you have,
Nick Frost and Simon Pegg are huge,
you know,
UK comedians and then,
but you have a lot of my python influences are as well.
The whole world seems almost
kinda like a Charles Dickens kind of story.
And you,
I mean you have like the one ton weight,
which I don't know if that was a reference to money pie thrown out.
But then you have also that scene where snatcher kind of guess has that low
allergic reaction.
And that's from them.
Now when we read the book,
Allen knows book,
he's English,
he's,
he's eccentric.
Um,
he's a really great,
he's really great guy and has a lot of crazy influences.
That was the tone of the book project as Python esque.
So we discussed for a minute with let's set it in Boston,
you know,
and that lasted about half the meeting.
Uh,
no,
it was always going to stay that way.
So it seemed natural and luckily for us,
Travis had no problem with that.
There'd be very few animation studios in the country where they would agree to
an all in English cask using Pitbull,
like Richard Iowa,
they and stuff who aren't that well known here.
But Travis never blinked.
Um,
you know,
he thought it was appropriate if he wouldn't have had it,
any,
any revenge.
I mean,
Harry Norman was a film set in Salem,
Massachusetts,
essentially directed by two British fellow
and they made it
ugly and stuff.
So we made these guys and look,
as you can see,
there's not a straight tooth in the thing.
So it's our revenge on Chris and Sam and uh,
you know,
deep rarely baker and Steve Lemm,
they kind of,
you know,
the really,
really talented voice artists and they kind of created the whole box troll
voices and their whole dialogue.
You know,
I do a lot of influences.
They set from like cling on and Java,
you know,
language and I kind of want to talk about,
and Tracy Morgan and wells has,
he plays,
he is,
so
he has almost language.
Do you find it that you kind of like what,
what was the development of that language and when you guys kind of landed on
that,
that was another thing that grew in the whole,
it was one of the things we're early on,
we had all these great aspirations of maybe writing dictionaries of Buck's row
language and have all the words and things be consistent and specific.
Uh,
and that's kind of what you brought to d and Steve initially and they tried it
out.
But once we paired it up with what we had in terms of the character designs and
where the story was that it felt wrong.
It felt too sophisticated,
don't like cling on and didn't feel like Kleenex box rules.
We're going through the right of ascension
just didn't seem appropriate.
Yeah.
Steve and d were huge,
hugely helpful and finding ways to simplify that language down into something
that was more emotive and gestural but wasn't so specific and didn't have this
sort of consistent thing where you felt like you needed a dictionary.
You knew through the sounds with the box tools were getting at,
but you didn't hear like individual wards so much.
It was much more selective and they were just incredible at improvising
that stuff.
Yeah,
it was really unique.
It was great.
And so,
and you talked about love about this in your talk,
but where do you kind of start to define the line of where you're going to go,
stop motion,
where you're going to go CG,
whatever delivers the style and it's,
yeah,
rising.
I mean,
yeah,
like all through the process.
It would surprise us where we would presume going into a breakdown,
meaning that something would be v effects digital and it would end up being
practical and vice versa.
Yeah.
And we're not purist.
I mean there's a lot of people who come to stop motion and they want to stay
practical.
You know,
they want to stick with an idea of stop motion where,
and it can be incredibly charming.
Fantastic.
Mr. Fox nightmare before Christmas.
You know,
a lot of those films is they're gonna make their smoke out of cotton or their
rain out of gelatin.
And that stuff's incredibly charming.
And if that suits the tone and the story of the film,
that's great.
But in our film,
which we wanted to open it up a little,
make an action inventor inventing action,
adventure,
comedy,
um,
we didn't want you to ever see an effect of something that charmed you out of
the movie that threw you out of the movie.
It's like suddenly jeopardy feels real in the world,
feels really credible.
But then something is,
you know,
smoke is made out of cotton.
So we wanted to treat it our stop motion footage as if it was live action
footage and we were adding realistic special effects,
realistic but on style forum for our movie.
Yeah.
And you know,
you know,
you talked a lot about ballroom,
seeing and everything and that was,
I mean everything from the trolls cavern and the crowd shots and stuff was,
and I was actually pretty surprised that will fall a stop motion of them jumping
on top of each other in the boxes as well.
Then kind of like gathering up to go to sleep.
And was there any talk of that to doing that CG to kind of like,
hey did the CG back characters,
you always wanted to stop
golden rule in terms of like choosing practical or via effects in a situation as
a game.
Anything that the hero puppets interact with needs to be and should be
practical.
So everything was always designed with that at its core.
And then we would go from there.
However we wanted to enhance the moment and bring,
you know,
different effects into it.
But
yeah,
and it's not,
financially it's not worthwhile.
And we don't do it as there aren't computer avatars for the heroes.
We don't have a computer version of eggs or the most important eight boxtrolls.
So you always want those guys front and center anyway.
So even if part of the pile stacking around them later is CG,
when those guys are stacking their real puppets because we don't make copies of
them digital.
Yeah,
I do just,
you don't want to make the movie twice when you make a movie like this.
And so making a real eggs and a CGA eggs would sort of defeat the purpose and be
twice as expensive suddenly.
And did you find yourself pulling back on some of the VFX stuff?
Uh,
no.
No.
I mean the box for old cabin invasion.
In fact,
we,
uh,
there's a couple of animators they want to punch this out because when snatcher
invades the tunnel there and lands,
we animated that whole sequence before we add the effects of all the dust and
stuff dropping in.
And we kept telling the animators,
don't worry about animating the rocks rolling on the ground.
Don't worry about.
But they would do it every time.
So,
and when we added all the CG effects,
it covered up a lot of their most subtle bits of animation and stuff.
But we wanted it to look super destructive really over the top.
And was it helpful cause I mean obviously with all the sequences of having two
directors on this,
so being co directors as opposed to just one person.
Yeah,
I think when they,
when they,
you know,
during the pre production phase of it,
we're kind of joined at the hip and we are involved together on almost all the
meetings and decisions.
But once the shooting schedule begins,
that's where the studio really benefits from the fact that there's two of us to
be able to split between two different edit suites and we can kind of streamline
and make it as efficient as possible to all of animation launches.
We sort of split up on sequences where,
I mean it would constantly check in with each other all day long.
Yeah.
There's 55 stages going on.
This 27 animators working on,
they're all working on different shots.
This,
you know,
there's twice as many stages as animators cause you always want their next stage
to be setting up when they finish.
Um,
and so then those things,
you have to go out and meet with those animators each at least every other day
while they're working on they're shots you have set visit,
you walked with,
they're doing or they are completing their shots are completing the rehearsal
and new reviewing them in editorial.
And you never want an animator standing there waiting for director of input.
So that's when it's really important.
Uh,
and with the story too,
you know,
it got,
it didn't get as dark as the books.
The book is definitely a little bit darker.
Yeah.
I've got a little bit with,
with the,
you know,
when he's kind of discussion about the boxtrolls about how they were stealing
her morbid fascination,
but was there any,
uh,
any pushed by the studio by you guys even to pull back on that darkness or put
more in?
Or was this just kind of where it started ticking and you know,
it didn't have a supernatural element like Coraline did in Paranorman.
So we were kind of happy for that.
We definitely wanted it to brighten it up,
but we also felt from the very beginning that the property,
the story appealed for younger kids.
So we never wanted to jeopardize that.
We don't do focus screenings.
Travis doesn't believe in that stuff.
We,
we have our own kids and you know,
we make movies that we want to see and we judge them by our own kids.
And honestly,
I show it to my kid who's sick of seeing it and stuff to try to figure out the
moments that might be too powerful and stuff.
But we definitely believe that,
that,
um,
because we're an independent film studio and because Travis is,
is really has the vision for the studio that you want to find stories that are
willing to go a little bit darker because you need those lower depths to get the
high higher highs emotionally on the other end of the spectrum.
And honestly,
you know,
when you were growing up and you were watching Dumbo in Pinocchio and a lot of
those older farms,
they were willing to sort of go to some of those darker places and a lot of
other studios are,
are attached to big corporations and they can't take the risk.
They need to sort of stay in a sort of a middle ground there because their films
are so expensive to make and there's so much part of the merchandising stuff
that they can't risk alienating any possible facet of the public.
We don't have those constraints.
Gotcha.
So,
uh,
you know,
with you guys having this big success and you guys signed with focus for three
more movies and other not announced yet,
but where do you kind of see this going and kind of pushing,
cause obviously the ballroom sequence was a huge learning experience where you
guys,
would you guys ever tackle something like that again?
I was just like,
no,
we got it.
I actually have a couple apps I'd like to pitch and see if I [inaudible].
Yeah,
I know it's hard to predict because one of the things I've found really amazing
about working at like as each project has been very specific and Ben its own
thing,
certain things get learned and we evolve and the departments keep refining
things,
but,
and then each project brings a whole new set of problems,
a whole new set of challenges.
A couple of ago everybody
at the studio would jump when we call it now,
they completely ignores me and walked down the hallway the other day I was
talking to Brad Schiff,
our animation supervisor,
and he was like,
the faces on your movie are nothing compared to what they're doing.
They have five minutes now of the next film done and they've already started
doing stuff,
you know,
continued to push the rapid prototype process and stuff.
That's kind of what's fun about the place too because it gets boring for people
in the head of department to repeat stuff.
So they actually liked the challenges and stuff in the next film has a lot of
challenges.
Yes,
lower.
Excited to see it.
A Q and a for you guys.
So we got the first question.
Do you feel that animators who come from like a traditional or CG background get
better become better animators because they have to plan so much and uh,
basically do their final shot?
Just once.
I mean it's funny how many I had to stop motion animators.
You meet who that's predominantly what they do.
Um,
there's quite a few of the stop motion people I know quite a few start munching
enemies who stop motion is what they've always done and they've also,
they animate on the computer too.
I don't need so many animators and make the to transition the other way and
choose to go into stop motion later.
Partially for the reason that I described.
It's like all animation is hard and hard enough and then they look at what stop
motion animators do and they go,
oh,
I don't want to go anywhere near that.
But there are a lot of,
seems like quite a few statements.
Anatomies started out wanting to be two d animators,
but they couldn't draw or they didn't like all the drawing or they hated the
fact that in drawing you have to worry about stuff like volumes changing and
staying on model and stuff here and in CG.
In some ways you're freed up if you don't have great drafting skills,
if you don't like wearing about staying on model,
staying on the character design and stuff.
Here you're purely dealing with performance and timing,
which is something that certain animated,
that's what they love,
the best.
Others love drawing but,
but are you worried about,
is the performance that's going on here and stuff.
So that's why I think some CG animators in stop motion animators,
the world has been opened up to people who want to be animators but don't draw.
Um,
so I don't know how they get used to it except they've never known anything
else.
There are places where they do stop motion animation,
where there,
there was no rehearsals.
Um,
some TV stop motion and stuff like that.
Or people who've worked on Gumby and some of that oldest stop motion.
So in some ways as hard as what we do is it's actually luxurious compared to
other jobs that they've been on.
It's just that Travis has a very specific sort of,
um,
rigorous idea of the quality of the animation that they want.
So it is working at the highest level and I think that's probably the most
intimidating thing.
Yeah,
definitely.
I think the fact that,
yeah,
Travis is one of the lead animators and one of the best in the studio that a,
that department certainly feels the pressure to take,
keep their,
keep their a game up.
Okay.
So,
uh,
my question is actually about the,
the uh,
statement you made about,
uh,
using practical characters for anything that was going to touch another
character.
Is that a,
is that a about appearance or about performance?
It,
it's,
it's about difficulty.
It's just very hard to do.
Like had we had to do,
you know,
our plan initially on the chart where eggs is hiding under the skirt,
was to put a ring around the real puppets that were there that he was going to
interact with.
So they would dance into place and then eggs would grab the ring and lift it up
and we would use that ring as a guide to put in a CG skirt and stuff.
And that would just be very difficult and time consuming to do,
not impossible,
but just very hard to do.
So that's,
that's mainly in situations like that we'd like to just try to avoid it because
it's a lot,
it means a lot of,
you know,
rodeoing out hand painting frames and stuff like that.
So the way the process has developed that were more efficient to keep it all
practical and a lot of ways and there's this consistency to the appearance that
you don't have to worry that you're going to get into some weird realm or the
two things bumped together looking right.
And yeah,
like Tony said,
it just sounds like more performance or a single animator or clump of a team of
animators can worry about these two characters doing it.
Right.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Those are the two different worlds.
They have to be composited in it.
Yeah.
It goes back to sort of try,
you know,
making the movie twice instead of,
because you have the two worlds is one is always enhancing the other and stuff.
I mean there's some,
there's a couple of wide shots in there that are predominantly CG and then they
would just,
um,
you can do camera tricks and stuff to give you that wide views of the city and
stuff,
but that becomes problematic when you're doing stereo,
um,
into the,
uh,
three d stuff is those little cheats don't work as well in three d and stuff.
So there's always an answer to every problem,
but I don't know any of them.
I just sit in the room and wait,
let those guys at the other end of the table hash it out.
Yeah.
I was curious.
You've referred to cost a couple times and uh,
he said would double the cost to do both CG and
practical versions of the characters.
How does the cost actually compare overall versus doing this?
I actually tried to stay out of that as much as possible,
but I do know that all three of like his films cost less
to make than it takes to make one big Pixar film or one big dreamworks films,
you know in their films are upwards of $200 million in cost to make and stuff.
So these are significantly less even giving,
you know,
we have about 400 people at the peak that work on the films and that 18 month
project,
you know,
cycle.
When we start storyboarding and maybe five years ago or six years ago we started
really working on the story.
We have a very small crew and then the crew just gets bigger and bigger and
bigger to,
you hit that 18 months of production and then people start to drop off cause the
puppets are all made and the sets are all made and stuff.
So that that crew is,
is big.
It sounds like a lot,
but it's still not as significant as a big CG feature film.
We only have 25,
27 animators,
Pixar,
dreamworks,
some of those places,
they'll have 65 70 animators work on one of their films by the end of it and
there just aren't 60 or 75 really good stop motion animators in the world.
Even if you wanted to have throw that many bodies at the problem,
you,
you couldn't find them.
No,
no.
Last thing I want to talk about it,
it just,
was there any moment in the film that was just a,
your kind of favorite moment or your most proud moment that you guys able to
accomplish other than the ballroom scene was pronounced?
For me personally.
Yeah.
Snatchers end,
uh,
out of all the screenings we've attended and then I always make sure to sneak
into the theater to,
to be with the audience when that moment happens.
Cause for me,
storytelling.
Why is that?
It's definitely the most gratifying moment in the film for me.
When I first started on it,
I loved the story.
You know,
my son was born about the time I started reading it.
So he immediately felt like the boxtrolls would like these loss boys.
And it's the story of a lost boy.
And I started,
uh,
commuting from la up to Portland.
So I had a lost boy at home that I wasn't seeing.
So for me,
that,
that really appealed to me.
There's a little sequence in the film where eggs and Winnie are sitting on the
edge of the cavern and they're talking about what a father is.
And for a long time I kept quick keeping that in there.
And Travis like that film because I like that moment.
And Graham liked it because they both have young sons too.
And they know when you work in animation,
you are,
the definition of an animator is an absentee father.
Uh,
so you know,
that element was importantly,
but the story didn't need that moment for a lot of it's time.
And I always felt like that needs to be in the film.
That's at the core of the film.
It's really important.
But I had a hard time justifying it a lot of times to the story department.
They were like,
what is this big conversation when he's having,
when she's talking about a father doesn't seem to fit in there.
And eventually the film got to a place where that scene made sense.
So that was a scene where there was a lot of other scenes that I fight just as
hard for that died miserably.
But that one survived.
And for me,
that was one of those rare moments where the movie,
the story gets to breathe a little bit.
Yeah.
And it slows down.
And just,
you know,
for me,
it's the core of,
of sort of the emotional core of the film
and it's,
it's phenomenal.
So let's think a Tony and Graham [inaudible] boxtrolls will be available
digitally,
I think by the end of the month and then on,
uh,
disc soon after that.
So anyway.
Yeah.
So we look forward to you guys next film when that was announced and,
uh,
the guys all for joining [inaudible]
yeah.